tu as tourné son premier film de
philippe garrel je vais 17 ans il y en
avait dix neuf et ça s'appelait n'émeut
pas très fameux le sénat fait quoi parce
qu'un film de jeunes tu vas revue de pin
fume
oui et alors abbès jeune quoi je vais me
lancer dans une espèce de composition
est ce que je voulais je voulais jouer
un beau geste comme dans les films de
brice fond sa part légèrement flou et en
68 tu occupes l'odéon
ah bah oui qu'est ce qui se passe et
avait ensuite raconte pour les jeunes je
glande arango les alors moins de deux
ans à moi ouais ça commence comme ça un
jour il ya quelque chose qui me dit anne
aymone on veut occuper l'odéon alors
comme forcément va être encerclée donc
qu'il va falloir aller chercher des
vivres pour remplir le duo de vivre je
disais bon va falloir trouver la fois
bouillante et tout en avant l' aventure
on va chez castel on commence à dire
enquête pour acheter des vivres pour la
prise de l'odéon alors il ya paulo ce
qu'il faut je puisse y avait un abus
falloir tout le monde donne de l'argent
puis on avait un cahier pianotait machin
la mi-temps et toupie tout paris des
filets etc
avant la prise à la dure alors marc
daunis qui était excité comme une puce
qui allaient chercher des grands par
vous un peu un tapis du whisky ça peut
pas faire de mal et on partait avec ses
bons et puis un jour qu'elles font
arriver que la de shopping guide ça y
est c'est yellow et print agueda et en
france en réalité ce n'est pas vraiment
un siège 3 rebonds dans les stades où on
avait à manger normalement
et puis
il est plein de costumes qui traînaient
partout j'ai hérité chez lui commande
une une robe de chambre
sûrement d'un mario à l'ordre je partage
je ne porte plus que ça toute la journée
machin tout ça et c'était gai quartz est
ce qu'on arrive alors là elle après tu
es parti de 69 à 62 28 parties trois ans
je suis parti aux états unis pour suivre
un peintre dont tu étais très amoureuse
puis a laissé tomber sans un rond non
c'est à dire il n'a pas insisté mais le
quart brière à chartres ouais mais tu
t'es balader tafer marrakech qui ont
enflammé la route un peu et quand tu es
revenue en france c'était en 72 et tu
étais assez déçu parce que tu te disais
les gens sont tous en train de mourir de
de drogue et d'idéologie moi j'ai trouvé
le début des années soixante dix la
feria de baba cool précédemment le
moment où les gens ont commencé à
découvrir ses idées mais un peu tard
d'une façon qui étaient autrement et
cetera je trouve cette triste ces
années-là maîtrise directe a décidé de
partir à reims chez snc jouer phèdre et
ut aperçu que quand il jouait faivre des
gens rigolaient alors là c'est là que
j'ai rencontré la bande du splendid
entre 75 et ta carrière démarrée
toujours pas et tu as dit à ce moment là
si je suis pas célèbre à 30 ans je me
tue à damas et dix à 25 ans qui comme à
25 ans et est passé le rêve déjà poussé
jusqu'à 30 à mayenne damian wayne c'est
à dire que c'est vrai que des copains en
fait à l'origine qui m'avait dit c'est
angoissant de vouloir faire métier de
tailleur et puis il me dit mais tu sais
je t'assure si c'est une question de vie
ou de mort tu y arriveras jamais j'y
arrive pas je meurs ouais la suite
justement parlons de feu aux fesses tu
t'es retrouvé en simple
ouais tu savais pas de client paie
samedi tout exprès sinon quoi
oui j'ai fini par trouver à renoncer
maintenant oui vingt trois mois j mende
et la malaisie
et c'est là miracle la cellule miracle
quand même eu un miracle va rencontrer
philippe galland qui était l'homme de ta
vie pendant de longues années et tu fais
le père noël est une ordure qui a été
ton premier gros succès en fait gagner
chez moi d'abord bien sûr ma cuisine
comme chez moi là tu es devenu une belle
mais parce qu'après il y ait de sucre et
j'avais des grands rôles qui tel le père
noël le quart d'heure ma femme s'appelle
reviens et puis super ex trième aliens
après c'était vedette et là tu te paye
le luxe de faire en plus des choses de
qualité d'envoyer chier tout le monde
était capricieuse a quand même à
l'époque
non non non c'est une grande fille mais
si jamais été capricieuse le coût des
césar quand même c'était un peu
capricieux mais tu vas cette année sera
elle qui disait moi je viens convaincu
mais faut qu'on roule un patin en même
temps mais quel rapport était césar nous
sépare avoue que tu as eue c'est un
rapport avec ça si tu veux c'est à dire
qu'à un moment donné tu te retrouves à
faire une émission qui à l'époque
faisait encore un tout petit peu
d'audience et c'était un créneau
publicité grâce à 100000 quand même bon
et le créneau publicitaires
normalement dans ce que tu fais ça pour
le producteur mais si vraiment le
producteur il t'a rien donné
qu'est ce que tu vas les femmes créent
de terrain plus car c'est lié à l'état
foutu le bordel j'ai parlé mes bijoux
nommé rock de merde je voudrais plus bas
toi et ouais alors d'accord c'est ça
l'histoire
enfin tiens regarde aller sa plume prime
plantes pipeline soir à produire le soir
l'histoire des césar où tu avais été
donc meilleure actrice 87 je crois pour
le grand chemin de gens me huent bercé
sa fin j'étais au sommet c'était génial
de faire ça à toutes les filles
attendent leur césar comme ça pendant
des années toi tu arrives tu fout le
bordel tu fais la pub de ton copain qui
fait des bijoux etc
tu sais j'avais les chocottes de faire
ça parce que à l'époque c'était je
t'assure c'était carpet ce métier m'a
non ça bouge un peu
y'a pas nouveau film d'un jeune garry
plein de trucs qui bougent et tout je
jure qu'il ya eu un moment dans les
années 80 les années reagan tout était
figé le pognon c'était ça où tu étais
riche gagnant est là et tout allait bien
ou sinon tu étais là ni d'humanité
c'était d'une moquerie complètement
farce comme et moi j'avais super les
chocottes ce genre dans un ciel serein
tout ça puis d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup de
travail et c'est qu'on en parle encore
10 mois est ce que tu crois que les gens
dans la rue savent ce que tu as été
obligé de faire pour y arriver
renault sagem est là j'aurais bien aimé
coup chèques des producteurs mais
préfère me faire travailler pas un
produit